Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师Lisa Johnson共同发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。我是Marianne Trent博士，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. Now, if you are a regular listener or watcher, you might notice that A. The sound doesn't sound quite as good as it usually does and b if you are watching on youtube you might notice that i'm in a different location guilty as charged on both accounts and actually i'm probably doing the opposite of what i'm going to tell you to do in this episode so this episode is all about living your best life as an aspiring psychologist or a mental health professional because it's really important that we do in order to help us to manage the ebb and flow and the hustle and bustle and the kind of take-take nature that our jobs can feel like. So I am on tour currently.
我是Marianne Trent博士，是一名合格的临床心理学家。现在，如果你是常客，你可能会注意到：A. 音质听起来不如平时好；B. 如果你在YouTube上观看，你可能会发现我换了个地方。这两点我都承认，而且我现在的做法可能和我在这期节目中要告诉你们的恰恰相反。这期节目是关于作为一名有抱负的心理学家或心理健康专业人士，如何过上最好的生活，因为这对于我们应对工作中的起起落落、忙碌奔波以及那种“索取式”的职业感受非常重要。所以我现在正在度假。
I am on holiday. It's October half-term, and I am, I'd say, living some of my best life here, really. So where is here exactly? And if you're on YouTube, shall I show you where here is? So if you're listening, and even if you're watching what I'm doing is I'm showing you the estuary view from this window from the office window which is just wonderful I will level with you that this is the second time I've recorded this podcast episode so for some reason the microphone
我在休假。现在是十月的期中假，我可以说，我正在过着我最好的生活。那么，“这里”到底是哪里呢？如果你在看YouTube，要我展示一下这里是哪里吗？所以，如果你在收听，甚至在观看，我正在向你们展示窗外河口的景色，从办公室窗户看出去真是太美了。我得跟你们坦白，这是我第二次录制这期播客了，因为某种原因，麦克风
wasn't working and when I came to edit it it had no sound and a podcast with no sound is many things but it's not a podcast and unless you're really good at lip reading you're not going to get very much from that at all so when I I was recording it earlier, there was a windsurfer out there distracting me in the most joyful of ways. A slightly less joyful distraction is that in the house next door they're having a refurb. And so if you can hear banging and clanging, that is what that is. So, yes, why am I doing the episode today? So the episode kind of came to me because I just had a great day yesterday, really great. And I was just out and about on a kayak with my husband in the afternoon. So a really lovely time time this beautifully sunny day and just really making
当时没工作，当我准备剪辑时发现根本没有声音。一个没有声音的播客什么都不是，除非你非常擅长读唇语，否则你根本听不到什么内容。所以当我早些时候录制时，外面有一个风帆冲浪者，以一种最令人愉快的方式分散了我的注意力。稍微没那么令人愉快的分心是隔壁房子正在装修。所以，如果你能听到敲敲打打的声音，那就是原因。那么，是的，我为什么今天要录这期节目呢？因为昨天我过得非常棒，真的太棒了。下午我和丈夫去划了皮划艇。在阳光明媚的一天里度过了一段非常美好的时光，这真的
me reflect on the last time I'd been on a kayak with him which was I think in 2010 it's been a long time you know when you've got young children it's kind of it's kind of hard to kayak but we left them home with the grandparents yesterday and so yeah they were happy playing Roblox, whatever it it's lovely um as we were walking today I saw a sign that said something along the lines of Christ Church where time is pleasant and I think most people were like time is pleasant is pleasant really a word that we use when things are really really good or is it when things are like fine um but yes if i i was trying to decide whether if i lived here and this was the view from my window whether i'd be super super productive because i'd always want to sit at my desk or whether i would just end up laying down on the sofa with a similarly glorious view
让我回想起上次和他一起划皮划艇的时候，我想是在2010年。时间过得真快，你知道，当你有了年幼的孩子，划皮划艇是挺难的。但昨天我们把他们留给祖父母照顾了，所以他们玩Roblox玩得很开心，不管怎样，这很棒。嗯，今天散步时，我看到一个牌子，上面写着类似“基督城，时间是愉快的”之类的话。我想大多数人会觉得，“时间是愉快”真的是我们形容事情非常好时会用的词吗？还是说这只是指事情“还行”？但确实，我一直在纠结，如果我住在这里，这就是我窗外的景色，我会变得超级高效，因为我总是想坐在书桌前，还是说我最终会躺在沙发上看着同样壮丽的景色，
and not get very much done at all. So as I do sit here, I think, oh, if I wrote a book here, it would be just a lovely, lovely view. So when I was writing the Aspiring Psychologist psychologist collective and doing the editing for that I went away with a week for a weekend with my friends and before they arrived I sat and overlooked the most beautiful Malvern Hills view and that was really inspiring so I'm all about the view and that's one of my top tips really is you know if you are feeling a bit bogged down by life and the views around you then could you get out and about to even have a day of looking at something a little bit more awe-inspiring so I wrote a piece for the
而什么也做不成。所以当我坐在这里时，我想，哦，如果我在这里写一本书，这景色真是太美了。所以当我在写《有抱负的心理学家集体》并进行编辑时，我和朋友们去度了个周末。在她们到达之前，我坐在那里俯瞰着最美丽的马尔文山景色，那真的非常鼓舞人心。所以我非常推崇这种景观，这也是我的顶级建议之一：如果你觉得生活和周围的景色让你感到压抑，那么你能否出去走走，哪怕花一天时间去看看那些更令人敬畏的事物呢？所以我写了一篇文章
media a while ago that suggested that when we're seeing and experiencing awe-inducing things that we have a better quality of life so where could you look in your life to even have low cost awe so it might be going to a forest you know with really big tall trees where you can kind of just appreciate the difference in size and how long it would have taken for those trees to grow so tall or it might be going out to see some water you know big strong winds today's definitely wouldn't have been kayaking today although my little boy did want to go kayaking before you still want quite that safe oh you'll be pleased to know our favorite wind surfer is back but is
媒体前段时间建议，当我们看到并体验到令人敬畏的事物时，我们的生活质量会更高。那么，你可以在生活中寻找什么来获得低成本的“敬畏感”呢？比如去森林，那里有非常高大的树木，你可以欣赏它们体型的差异，以及这些树长到这么高需要多长时间；或者去看看水，今天风很大，肯定不适合划皮划艇，尽管我儿子还是想去。哦，你会很高兴知道我们最喜欢的风帆冲浪者回来了，但
if I can show you so you obviously took a little bit of a break. Maybe he wanted to have some hot chocolate and warmed up. Another lovely, comforting thing that you can also do. So for those of you listening, what I'm doing is I'm showing a lovely man on his white and blue water surfer. Is it? Wind surfer. Wind surfer is it wind surfer wind surfer so as he whips about now i'm sure he will distract me in the most wonderful of ways um but yeah i went uh wind surfing in 2010 it was very very difficult um i went on one of those nielsen holidays had an absolutely brilliant time and so that was and I was just about starting my third year of doctoral training so yeah very very much recommend going out and doing some active things if you can to help you
如果我能展示给你看，他显然休息了一会儿。也许他想喝杯热巧克力暖暖身子。这是你可以做的另一件可爱、舒适的事情。所以对于那些正在收听的人，我正在展示一个可爱的男人在玩他的白蓝色风帆冲浪板。是风帆冲浪吗？风帆冲浪。当他现在飞驰而过时，我相信他会以最美妙的方式分散我的注意力。嗯，是的，我在2010年去玩过风帆冲浪，非常非常难。我参加了那种尼尔森假期，度过了一段非常棒的时光。那是我刚开始第三年博士培训的时候，所以非常推荐大家尽可能去参加一些户外活动，帮助你
get through whatever you've got going on in your life now but it's really important that we are living some of our best life ideally even when we're waiting to kind of get to where you think might be the good stuff where all the good stuff happens we need to be enjoying life along the way too one of my next top tips is when you get a new diary for the year this is mine I favour an A4 diary like lots of room is to think about best case scenario and if you could get all of your choice of annual leave what would you want and make sure that you are ideally booking it if you're part of a team
度过生活中正在经历的一切。但重要的是，我们要过上最好的生活，理想情况下，即使在我们等待到达你认为“好事发生”的地方时，我们也需要享受沿途的生活。我的下一个顶级建议是，当你拿到新的一年的日记本时——这是我的，我喜欢A4大小的日记本，因为空间很大——要考虑最理想的情况。如果你能选择所有的年假，你想要什么？确保你理想情况下已经预订了它。如果你是团队的一员，
or if you are self-employed like me that you're just taking it out of there as not available for bookings because it's really really nice actually when you are doing client work and you're looking for the next available appointment and then you flick past you know annual leave and you think oh yes oh I have got that thing coming up oh brilliant so I tend to put all of my social things into my work diary as well to give me like a little bit of a boost as well when I'm flicking through the diary I think oh yeah that thing's coming up oh I'm really looking forward to that that'll be really good to help bolster where you're at now so yeah that's something you might like to consider but it's really important to me as a parent that I'm having time with the children when they're on half-term breaks so even before the
或者像我一样是自雇人士，你只需要把它标记为“不可预订”。因为当你处理客户工作并寻找下一个可用预约时，翻过年假那一页，你会想：“哦，对了，我有那个活动要参加，太棒了。”所以我倾向于把所有的社交活动也写进工作日记里，当我翻看日记时，这也能给我一点动力，我想：“哦，对了，那件事快到了，我真的很期待。”这对于支撑你现在的状态非常有帮助。所以，这是你可以考虑的事情。但作为一名家长，对我来说，在孩子们期中假时陪伴他们非常重要。所以即使在
half-term holidays and the school term dates get published what I do is I am earmarking those I'm looking on the local government website to look for the term times and making sure that where possible I book out as much time as I can to be off with the children during half terms so that I can have a good break sorry about the noise next door that I can decompress you know because we carry a heavy load in the work that we do and so making sure that we're able to maximize our time off is really key and of course we don't always want to be away from home sometimes it's nice just to have down time to be at home to enjoy you know this space that you've created you know and have a little bit of R&R from right where you sit and right where you live. So it's
期中假和学校学期日期公布之前，我就会把它们标记出来。我会在当地政府网站上查看学期时间，并确保尽可能多地预订时间，以便在期中假期间与孩子们在一起，这样我就可以好好休息一下。抱歉隔壁有噪音。我需要减压，因为我们所做的工作负荷很重，所以确保我们能够最大化利用休假时间是关键。当然，我们并不总是想离家，有时在家享受你创造的空间，在你的居住地进行一点休息和放松（R&R）也是很好的。所以
not all about rushing out and spending money, but it's about having time to just relax and to do the things you like to do. Might that be naps? Could be. I absolutely used to love a nap. Or just to go out for walks in your local area, or a little bit further afield. You know, you could head to the seaside for a day and have fish and chips. You know, small pleasures can be very richly rewarding indeed. So don't think that life is suddenly going to become glorious when you're qualified. You know, we need to be working hard to create a life that you're enjoying along the way um and then of course we hope that the same continues when you are qualified
这并不全是关于冲出去花钱，而是关于有时间去放松，去做你喜欢做的事情。可能是小睡？有可能。我以前绝对喜欢小睡。或者只是在当地散步，或者去远一点的地方。你知道，你可以去海边待一天，吃炸鱼薯条。你知道，小小的快乐确实可以带来丰富的回报。所以不要认为当你获得资格后，生活会突然变得辉煌。我们需要努力创造一种你沿途就能享受的生活，当然，我们希望当你获得资格后，这种状态能持续下去。
trying my best to dodge the incredibly noisy noises but if it goes on for much longer i might just need to plow on through regardless um so yeah as I said before this is the second time I've recorded this and so um I think the light is probably more favorable now it was a little bit sunny earlier it was in my eyes um but it might mean that we have a slightly shorter podcast episode as well because I've done it all already I know where I'm gonna go and also quite keen to go and sit downstairs and have a cup of tea so um yeah get your diary fill it in request the leave you know and if you're part of a team it might well mean that you've got to negotiate what you're going to have but it's really important
我正在尽力躲避那些极其嘈杂的声音，但如果再持续下去，我可能就得不管不顾地继续录了。所以，正如我之前所说，这是我第二次录制这期节目，我想现在的光线可能更好了，之前阳光有点刺眼，直射我的眼睛。但这可能意味着我们的播客会稍微短一点，因为我已经录过一遍了，我知道我要讲什么。而且我也很想下楼去喝杯茶。所以，是的，拿上你的日记，填好它，申请休假。如果你是团队的一员，这可能意味着你必须协商你的休假时间，但非常重要的一点是
that we're not just you know saving all our leave until the end of the leave year often in the NHS that will run until the end of March beginning year often in the nhs that will run until the end of march beginning of april but we don't want you to be having you know just lots of fallow time um in in the new year it's important to try and spread out that leave as much as you can and i know that um bank holidays are likely pro-ratted and they certainly were when I was in the NHS but please use your leave not just in one go please try to make sure that you're using it to enrich your life your soul your spirit everything about you so that you're not just totally burned out all the time and we need to think about the power of evenings and weekends and holiday as well. I'm being a bad girl
我们不能把所有的假期都留到年底。在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）中，假期通常持续到三月底或四月初。我们不希望你在新年里有太多的空闲时间，尽量把假期分散开来。我知道银行假日通常是按比例分配的，我在NHS时确实如此，但请使用你的假期，不要一次性用完。请尽量确保你用它来丰富你的生活、灵魂、精神，以及你的一切，这样你就不会一直处于精疲力竭的状态。我们需要考虑晚上、周末和假期的力量。我是一个坏榜样，
because I'm working on my holiday, but I'm choosing to work on my holiday because it matters to me that you guys have a new podcast episode to look forward to each week as well, because I know that many of you have this as part of your weekly routine and thank you from the bottom of my heart if that does describe you. So, yeah, using your evenings and weekends. And when I first got together with my husband, he was like, why don't you have more hobbies? Why do you not do more things? I was like, well, I like a bit of pilates. I like chatting with my friends.
因为我在假期里工作，但我选择在假期工作，因为你们每周都能期待一期新的播客对我来说很重要。我知道你们很多人已经把它作为每周例行公事的一部分，如果这描述的是你，我从心底里感谢你。所以，是的，利用好你的晚上和周末。当我刚和我丈夫在一起时，他问：“你为什么没有更多的爱好？你为什么不多做点事情？”我说：“嗯，我喜欢普拉提，喜欢和朋友聊天。”
I like going out for dinner. I like naps. Naps are a key hobby and if you are lucky enough to still have naps in your life, perhaps you don't yet have children or you have some magical method of ignoring them so that you can nap, please let me know. Tag me when you've had a really good nap, won't you? Come and talk to me about your naps on the Aspiring Psychologist community on Facebook. Yeah, I love a good nap. Love a good nap. My in-laws are currently asleep right now on the sofa downstairs because they've come along away with us. That was noisy. That was noisy. That's not them snoring. That's not them snoring. That is the work people next door.
我喜欢出去吃晚餐，喜欢小睡。小睡是一个关键的爱好。如果你足够幸运，生活中还能有小睡的时间，也许你还没有孩子，或者你有某种神奇的方法可以忽略他们以便小睡，请告诉我。当你睡了个好觉时，记得艾特我，好吗？来Facebook上的“有抱负的心理学家”社区和我聊聊你的小睡。是的，我喜欢小睡，非常喜欢。我的公婆现在正在楼下的沙发上睡觉，因为他们和我们一起来了。刚才那声音太吵了。那不是他们打呼噜的声音，那是隔壁装修工人的声音。
So, yeah, try to make sure that you've got things to look forward to in your evenings and weekends, but don't over cram them. Just because there's a gap in your social calendar doesn't mean you need to fill it so I'm trying to adopt the kind of the concept of not booking more than two things over a week to do because I'll just be burned out you know and it's tricky to do anyway because the children seem to relentlessly have football I was going to say football rehearsal football practice and training and actual matches and stuff so yeah gone are the days where my weekends are my own anyway but yeah I was really just I enjoy my work you know and I did as an aspiring psychologist so if you're not really enjoying your work as an aspiring
所以，尽量确保你的晚上和周末有值得期待的事情，但不要把它们塞得太满。社交日历上有空档并不意味着你需要填满它。我正在尝试采用一种“每周不超过两件事”的概念，因为否则我会精疲力竭。而且这本来就很难做到，因为孩子们似乎有没完没了的足球练习、训练和正式比赛。所以，我的周末早已不再属于我自己了。但我确实享受我的工作，作为一名有抱负的心理学家时也是如此。所以，如果你作为一名有抱负的心理学家并没有真正享受你的工作，
psychologist it might be an idea to reflect on how different you envisage qualified life to be when you get there because in my experience they're not vastly different you know I do more media now I do obviously write books and things and I do podcasts but my day-to-day work isn't that different really and so yeah think about where you might be able to crank up the joy perhaps using supervision to think about creating more opportunities within your work to do the things that you really really do enjoy might be useful so what we'll do is we'll take a short break here um and i'll be back along very soon if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified.
也许可以反思一下，你预想的获得资格后的生活会有多大不同，因为根据我的经验，它们并没有太大的区别。我现在做更多的媒体工作，写书，做播客，但我的日常工作并没有太大变化。所以，想想你可以在哪里增加快乐，也许利用督导来思考如何在工作中创造更多机会去做你真正喜欢的事情，这可能会很有用。那么，我们在这里休息一下，我很快就会回来。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南，书中充满了能帮助你获得资格的经验和教训。
So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective My name is Diakolola Amujam. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective
来看看吧，就在这本书里。它是《临床心理学家集体》。它是《临床心理学家集体》。我的名字是Diakolola Amujam。我是一名来自爱尔兰的心理学应届毕业生。我也是一名有抱负的临床心理学家。Marianne博士的书《临床心理学家集体》
has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UK DeclinSci application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and training clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favourite part of the book, as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology
在我成为临床心理学家的旅程中非常有帮助。当我计划在英国继续研究生学习时，我发现这本书提供了关于英国临床心理学博士申请流程的深入信息，这非常有用。我喜欢阅读合格的临床心理学家和实习生的经历。各种叙述是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都不同，它为临床心理学之旅提供了惊人的见解。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣
and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Thank you for coming back to me and hope you found this first half useful so far. So, yeah, in the first half, we were thinking about the blank diary and the power of evenings and weekends.
并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南。书中充满了能帮助你获得资格的经验和教训。来看看吧，就在这本书里。它是《临床心理学家集体》。它是《临床心理学家集体》。感谢回到节目，希望你觉得上半部分有用。所以，在上半部分，我们讨论了空白的日记和晚上及周末的力量。
I was also chatting to somebody today, actually, who's gone straight from being an aspiring psychologist and working really long hours with zero downtime and zero annual leave to go straight to doctoral training and finding that after teaching block and kind of hustling and jostling to form cohort relationships and expectations from the university as well as new placement expectations and pressures both self-imposed and supervisor imposed finding they're feeling a bit burned out already which is really really tricky and so I really do advocate using your diary to think well if I were to get on to doctoral training this year what could my summer look like what could I afford to how long could I afford to potentially not work for or could I use some of my annual leave to take before I finish to make sure I have a really enjoyable break so when I started training as you might know already because I talk about it quite
今天我还和一个人聊天，她从一名有抱负的心理学家，每天工作很长时间，没有休息时间，没有年假，直接进入了博士培训。她发现，在教学模块之后，为了建立同伴关系和应对大学的期望，以及新的实习期望和压力（无论是自我施加的还是督导施加的），她已经感到有点精疲力竭了，这真的很棘手。所以我真的提倡利用你的日记来思考：如果我今年能进入博士培训，我的夏天会是什么样子？我能负担得起多久不工作？或者我能否利用我的一些年假在结束前休息，以确保我有一个非常愉快的假期？当我开始培训时，正如你可能已经知道的，因为我经常谈论它，
a lot I'd had just the most wonderful summer I'd been away backpacking with a friend in Spain and Morocco and then I came back and finished off my work in the service I was working in and then went away to India for five weeks too and also I seem to recall I went to Barcelona with a very big group of assistant psychologists. I think we already knew we were going to be on training at that point and it was just such fun until I got mugged but even then on the other side of that it was such fun we had a great time and so it was just a really wonderful summer and so I really came to clinical training just energized, enthusiastic, tanned, happy, you know, living my best life. I'm really excited for this next stage. So yeah, where could you imagine or hope or dream that you might spend
我度过了一个最美好的夏天。我和朋友在西班牙和摩洛哥背包旅行，然后回来完成了我所在服务机构的工作，接着又去了印度五周。我还记得我和一大群助理心理学家去了巴塞罗那。我想那时我们已经知道我们要去参加培训了，那真是太有趣了，直到我被抢劫了。但即使在那之后，那依然非常有趣，我们度过了一段美好的时光。所以那真是一个非常美妙的夏天，我带着活力、热情、晒黑的皮肤和快乐进入了临床培训，过着我最好的生活。我对下一个阶段感到非常兴奋。所以，如果你在进入博士培训之前这是你的最后一个夏天，你可以在哪里想象、希望或梦想
this summer if this is your summer before you go on to doctoral training so yeah dare to dream and um just before the first time I recorded this podcast episode there's a book here just behind me called the best moment of your life and it's about um it's about a hundred stories it's a bit of a collective actually a hundred stories um written by people who have had, you know, really amazing moments. And one of them, the first story is actually something that I've already done, which I thought was incredible. So I haven't had a chance to look through it, really. But it's about someone who went to Varanasi in India and lit these little candles and then put them out across the Ganges and you do that with kind of mindful hope a connection to people that you've loved and lost and to for your hopes and
度过这个夏天呢？所以，敢于梦想。在第一次录制这期播客之前，我身后有一本书叫《你生命中最美好的时刻》，它讲述了大约一百个故事，是一个集体创作，由那些拥有真正惊人时刻的人撰写。其中第一个故事是我已经做过的事情，我觉得这太不可思议了。我还没有机会真正翻阅它，但它讲述了一个人去了印度的瓦拉纳西，点燃了这些小蜡烛，然后把它们放在恒河上。你带着一种正念的希望，与你爱过和失去的人建立联系，并为你的未来希望和
dreams in future and so I've done that and it was really it was like a really nice spiritual thing to do so that was really nice that made me reflect upon some of the other really lovely things I've done as well like going to Australia and driving around the world's largest sand island which is Fraser Island and you know encouraging the dingoes not to steal our barbecue and pitching a tent and sleeping out there and sleeping under the stars in the Thar desert and riding a camel which I talk about in the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book and what other things, hanging out in Thailand and swimming with dusky dolphins in New Zealand like and all of these were you know things that I've done whilst being an aspiring psychologist you know so in chunks of time that I've taken um to go out there and see
梦想祈祷。我做过这件事，这是一种非常美好的精神体验。这让我反思了我做过的其他一些非常可爱的事情，比如去澳大利亚，环绕世界上最大的沙岛——弗雷泽岛开车，鼓励澳洲野狗不要偷我们的烧烤，搭帐篷露营，在塔尔沙漠的星空下睡觉，骑骆驼（我在《有抱负的心理学家集体》一书中提到过），还有什么呢？在泰国闲逛，在新西兰和暗色海豚一起游泳。所有这些都是我在作为一名有抱负的心理学家时所做的事情，在我抽出时间去看看
the world but also nourish my soul you know and actually I don't know if I'd be here without doing that because on the days that are tricky I've very much drawn on many of those experiences so how could you do the things that nourish your soul you know that might be dancing it might be singing it might be traveling it might be eating great food or cooking great food or spending time with people you really enjoy spending time with so how can you look to do that because all work and no play makes life not feel very enriching so yeah that was a loud noise how can you do that as well and we need to make sure we're looking forward to things so So having things to look forward to. So, for example, comedy gigs maybe.
世界的同时，也滋养了我的灵魂。实际上，我不知道如果没有这些经历，我会不会在这里，因为在那些棘手的日子里，我非常依赖这些经历。所以，你如何做那些滋养你灵魂的事情呢？可能是跳舞、唱歌、旅行、吃美食、烹饪，或者与你真正喜欢的人共度时光。所以，你怎么能去寻找这些机会呢？因为只工作不玩耍会让生活感觉不那么丰富。是的，那是一个很大的噪音。你如何做到这一点？我们需要确保我们有期待的事情。所以，拥有值得期待的事情。例如，喜剧演出。
I was supposed to be going to John Richardson tomorrow, but we had to cancel because it had originally been scheduled for the pandemic. And then it rolled forward and moved to a date I couldn't do. So we had to refund it which was a shame but yeah I might well look to think what other comedy gigs I can get booked in trips to see friends meals in restaurants I'd like to go to you know family I might like to catch up with I've got a shopping trip with a couple of different friends university friends and psychology undergraduate friends. Yeah, so what can you do that might enrich your life and help decompress, you know, take off some of the pressure from this pressure cooker of life that we get
我本来明天要去看John Richardson的演出，但我们不得不取消，因为它最初是在疫情期间安排的。后来它推迟到了我无法参加的日期，所以我们不得不退票，这很遗憾。但我可能会考虑还能预订哪些喜剧演出、去见朋友、去我想去的餐厅吃饭、与我想叙旧的家人见面。我和几个不同的朋友有购物计划，包括大学朋友和心理学本科同学。是的，你可以做些什么来丰富你的生活并帮助减压？你知道，减轻我们作为心理健康专业人士或任何支持和关心他人的角色时，
when we are working as a mental health profession or any kind of role where you're supporting and caring about others. And along those lines, I would say it's really important to use supervision as well. And we can use supervision to look forward as well and to think about when you, you know, where you might like to go, you know. And we can also use any yearly appraisal to think about what experiences you might like to have to, you you know shape you and direct you and point you in the direction that you want to go don't be afraid to say that you're not thinking this is going to be your forever job you know it's absolutely okay to want to go to different places so perhaps you want to be a senior pwp or a senior assistant psychologist or perhaps you want
所感受到的生活压力锅的压力。沿着这些思路，我想说利用督导也非常重要。我们可以利用督导来展望未来，思考你想去哪里。我们还可以利用年度评估来思考你想要什么样的经历来塑造你、引导你，并指向你想要的方向。不要害怕说你并不认为这会是你永远的工作，想要去不同的地方是完全没问题的。也许你想成为一名高级PWP或高级助理心理学家，或者也许你想
to get your first kind of assistant psychologist role for example a research assistant role and i would say i hope you're in an environment where you're able to be honest about that and they can help support you um to get to this next step of the rung of the ladder which is going to be so useful for you um so this is a slightly brief episode and it was originally i think we came in about 29 minutes before but there was more distraction available with more windsurfing discussion opportunities and we've had more of a focus the last episode was a little bit a little bit woolly and a little bit too relaxed whereas now i was slightly annoyed when I started this because I
获得你的第一份助理心理学家职位，例如研究助理职位。我想说，我希望你所处的环境能够让你诚实地表达这一点，他们可以支持你迈向阶梯的下一步，这对你非常有用。所以，这是一期稍微简短的节目，我想之前我们录了大约29分钟，但有更多的分心机会，比如更多的风帆冲浪讨论。上一期节目有点模糊，有点太放松了，而现在，当我开始录制时，我有点恼火，因为我
can't believe I filmed an entire podcast and there was no sound and I checked it and everything but yes I came and did a redo and if there's no sound this time then frankly you're just gonna have to listen to no sound and to try and work out what I was saying but yeah I've done away with the airpods and you might have slightly worse sound and also quite a lot of noise to put up with and you might be able to hear buffeting wind as I sit here in this office room looking out at the wonderful estuary views so yeah if you found this useful then please come and discuss it with me on socials tell me about your naps as well I'm very excited about naps even when they're not my own um yeah and talk to me about your hobbiesaps as well. I'm very excited to buy naps, even when they're not my own.
不敢相信我录制了整个播客却没有声音，我检查了一切。但是的，我重录了一遍。如果这次还是没有声音，坦白说，你只能听不到声音，然后试着猜我在说什么。但我放弃了AirPods，音质可能会稍微差一点，而且还要忍受很多噪音，当你坐在这间办公室里看着窗外美妙的河口景色时，你可能会听到风声。所以，如果你觉得这有用，请在社交媒体上和我讨论，告诉我你的小睡情况。即使不是我自己的小睡，我也对小睡感到非常兴奋。
Yeah, and talk to me about your hobbies and your past terms. Come and discuss it with me on the Aspiring Psychologist Community, brackets free group, that's on Facebook. And yeah, if you would welcome some more support, then come along to the Aspiring Psychologist membership. Details in the show notes. And also, the day this episode is released is Halloween, the 31st of October.
是的，和我聊聊你的爱好和期中假。来“有抱负的心理学家社区”（Facebook上的免费群组）和我讨论吧。如果你需要更多支持，欢迎加入“有抱负的心理学家”会员计划，详情在节目说明中。另外，这期节目发布的日子是万圣节，10月31日。
And so we've got a live Q&A, compassionate Q&A across my socials as well. Do bear in mind if you're joining on Twitter, I can't see your comments live. So perhaps come along, Dr. Marianne Trent, most other places, but also on Facebook for Good Thinking Psychological Services too. So yeah come and see me, ask me questions, let me answer them for you
所以我们会在我的社交媒体上进行一场直播问答，一场富有同情心的问答。请记住，如果你在Twitter上加入，我无法实时看到你的评论。所以也许可以来Dr. Marianne Trent的页面，或者Facebook上的“Good Thinking Psychological Services”。所以，来见我，问我问题，让我为你解答。
and bearing in mind there's a competition running until midnight on the 31st of october as well more details for how you can win a one-to-one with me are available to you at www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash my hyphen books and you can see all the details there that you need to know um but yes thank you for joining me i'm going to go and hope there's some sound on this episode. Maybe see if I can get a little bit of a glass of wine on the go, maybe. It's a little bit of a random Wednesday afternoon off work. And, yeah, look forward to the fish and chips that we're having for tea tonight, which I seem to be aware have got rather good reviews from the local GP. So, yes, I hope you found this useful.
请记住，比赛将持续到10月31日午夜。关于如何赢取与我一对一辅导的更多详情，请访问 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/my-books，你可以在那里看到所有你需要知道的细节。感谢你的加入，我希望这期节目有声音。也许看看我能不能喝上一杯葡萄酒。这是一个随机的周三下午休假。是的，期待今晚我们要吃的炸鱼薯条，据当地全科医生评价相当不错。所以，希望你觉得这期节目有用。
I hope you found it inspiring. Give yourself permission to allow yourself to do the things that make you smile and enrich your soul because it's going to be so important along the journey. I hope you found it useful. Thank you for being part of my world
希望你觉得它鼓舞人心。给自己许可，去做那些让你微笑并滋养你灵魂的事情，因为这在旅途中非常重要。希望你觉得它有用。感谢你成为我世界的一部分，
and I'll look forward to catching up with you for our next episode, which is available to you from 6am on Monday. Take care. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psych collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong
我期待在下一期节目中与你相见，节目将于周一早上6点发布。保重。我的名字是Jana，我是一名心理健康实习医生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，我发现关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有完美的成为心理学家的道路。这让我充满了信心，我并没有做错，
and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。